so my name is Joe Stein nice to meet
everybody and he's speaking to you about
real-time streaming and data pipelines
with Apache Kafka so when someone says
real-time streaming to me this is kind
of the picture that pops up them to my
head right I kind of see some public
interface some set of application or
applications and ultimately what they're
doing is trying to work with different
subsystems within a system right there
may be very discreet or systematic ways
that you're trying to link different
data that's flowing within your
infrastructure you may have some
persistent I availability cache sitting
underneath it and ultimately you know
when we're talking real-time at least
for the sake of our discussion let's
just say if it's under 10 seconds it's
it's real-time okay and I started
thinking about data pipelines I start
thinking about components right so let's
say you unscrew that subsystem and you
look at the subsystem that's sitting
underneath ultimately you have little
components that are sitting inside right
the component is emitting data as in as
an output and it's an input to another
component and real-time streaming with
data pipelines is that not just within a
subsystem but also across subsystems and
you want to do that with very low
latency so if you start to zoom out a
little bit right you screw the little
subsystem back together and you zoom out
and you start to look at the subsystems
and you look at you know what maybe
certain people's infrastructures right
you have a storm system you may have
some cassandra in there for doing high
availability caching you may have Hadoop
for some type of ad hoc reporting you
have a whole bunch of domain systems
right specifically to your business but
you still have those applications that
are essentially still trying to write
data and events of what's happening and
based on the events that are happening
they're still trying to get something
out after that this is really where
patchy Kafka comes in
if you zoom out even further right you
may even like span across availability
boundaries I don't want to call them
zones or data centers but just
availability
boundaries and you start to see we're
having a central system to basically
handle these different data pipelines
you know maybe make sense so before we
get started I didn't really know where
everyone was when it came to Kafka you
know maybe it's zero in that you never
even heard of it before and you saw
something on a meet-up and it looked
interesting and you wanted to learn all
the way to hey you're running it in
production right now and you can't wait
for zero eight one and zero nine and
everything else so I did is try to base
the presentation for everybody if you go
and you can check out the sample code
for this presentation is up on github
all the Kafka code is open source so you
can go and download it and look at it
the documentation is fantastic right
it's written in English for humans if
you want to know what Kafka is doing
look at the code because that is written
for the computer just you know
documentation humans code computer but
between the two of them you can really
get everything that you need to out of
it there's a wiki a whole bunch of good
stuff on the wiki is wiki's go there's a
whole area of presentations and papers
so if you've seen any Kafka
presentations or you haven't and this is
gonna be a first one still go check
these out because a lot of stuff is out
there already and I'm not gonna really
rehash or cover too much that's already
been spoken about and try to you know
keep the community moving forward which
all of you are now part of the community
so welcome and then there's some tools
that you are gonna want to take a look
at the replication tools I'm in progress
starting to document some of the other
tools that are out there but for right
now you're just gonna have to kind of go
and look at the source code and you know
there's good documentation inside of the
code good comments so what all the
different arguments are and how you run
them but you kind of have to go to the
class files right now to do that oh
thanks
okay so patchy Kafka it's fast what I
mean by fast is your bottleneck is going
to be your network
all right Kafka was built in such a way
that the brokers are basically taking
data off of the socket and appending it
directly on disk okay
your bottleneck is your network all
right there's a lot of other benefits
and features that are in Kafka to make
it fast such as batching and compression
and you know I could talk for 30 minutes
about that but let's just you know take
it that it's fast it's Kafka scalable
right so Kafka allows you to actually
have multiple dozens hundreds even
different consumers reading off of the
same stream at the same time other
systems that will call messaging systems
don't act like a commit log write Kafka
is a commit log just the same way that
you have a journal or a commit log in
your database think of Kafka as the
commit log for your data pipelines okay
it's the commit log for your
infrastructure it tracks everything
that's happening and then allows
everyone to read off of the streams
without getting in the way of who else
is reading from it so everyone in this
room could be reading off of the Kafka
stream and the broker doesn't really
care it's happy to send you data as long
as your network is fast enough to you
know push all that data across Kafka is
durable now so in the 0.8.0 release
there is intercut inter inter cluster
replication and we'll talk a little bit
about you know your balance between
consistency and availability and how you
can kind of go back and forth depending
on what data you have maybe some of that
data needs to be more consistent versus
more available but it's durable now
we'll talk about that a little bit and
cough it's distributed by design right
the producers and the consumers are
completely decoupled from each other and
that makes for some very good design
patterns that we can introduce okay so
when I first started thinking about this
talk and sitting down I was like oh my
goodness you know I haven't actually sat
down and like from scratch wrote
something you know producer and consumer
and I looked and I was like well how do
people do this like how do you come in
and just start from nowhere
so what I
did was I spent a couple days and I put
together a kind of an example project so
that you could sit down and within five
minutes be completely up and running and
developing producers and consumers in in
Kafka so I don't know if anyone's ever
used vagrant before but vagrant is
basically a way to script virtual
machines it's awesome okay you say what
operating system you want you say after
boot what should be installed on the
operating system really really handy
tool Virtual Box is just a virtual
machine that can run a thread or two for
our development purses on a local
machine that's fine so you gotta get
those two installed but once that's
installed you clone the repo go into the
directory and you type vagrant up and
that's it
when vagrant up is done running you'll
have a zookeeper virtual machine running
and you'll have a broker virtual machine
virtual machine running and the broker
will be configured with zookeeper and at
that point you could just run the SPT
test so you just run the test cases
inside of the project and it will go and
run against the broker that is locally
running on your machine
so you've never used Kafka or you're
going to get started with Kafka you know
I would say start here really just like
spin up everything on your machine and
you know go start going through the
sample code which we're gonna start
doing a little bit for this talk all
right so if you use maven here's how you
get started with maven here's a pom that
you would use pom still needs a little
bit of work Kafka 1:1 600 is still open
to get rid of this little exclusion
clause but besides that you're good to
go if you have some other library that's
already excluding these libraries then
you don't have to do this but if you
don't then you do so here's your pom
file to kind of get going
I also recommend to use the Kafka 210
Scala 210 version for your dependencies
if you're not using any Scala version
then go with this one it's the latest if
you're still on an older version with
Scala okay good for you you know it's
all good talk about that some other time
an SPT it's just as simple if you don't
you know you have to throw in this and
transitive it's kind of
thing or like for me I pull in so many
different jar files that it's already
excluded I don't have that issue so
Kafka one one six zero if anyone else is
you know does SBT in their sleep and
wants to contribute I'm sure it's a
simple change in that build bill dot
Scala file if nobody else gets to it by
zero a one release then I will spend a
Saturday night and fix it promise
but hopefully someone else can
contribute and I could take a look and
commit it back to the project okay so
let's talk a little bit about at shikaka
producers consumers and brokers
ultimately everything is going to fall
into one of those three categories when
we talk about producers we're gonna
start talking about topics right so
topics are kind of where you're putting
your group of information and your group
of information is really dictated by
everything else that we're about to talk
about for the next 45 minutes or so so
I'm not gonna get too much into it with
producers but your topic name could be
anything it could be the hour of a day
which is great especially if you're
trying to do batch reconciliation
because if a server goes down for 20
minutes and it comes up two hours later
when it pushes its data back into the
commit log it'll do it at the specific
time an hour of the day you can produce
to multiple topics as well so there's a
lot of different ways that you can use
topics and the design patterns of your
system and we'll talk a little bit about
that we talked about brokers and kind of
the role that brokers play with
producers now in 0.8 and how they
control things like load balancing we
talked about sink producers and async
producers and I'm gonna introduce
everyone to the a sink sink producer
right so this is a acha producer that
wraps around your existing producer that
gives you control between consistency
and availability when you're producing
data to Kafka so we'll talk a little bit
about that on the consumer side we're
gonna talk a little bit more about
topics because topics are really a way
of grouping partitions so we'll talk
about partitions partitions mean how
many do you need really how to figure
out how many you need so kind of like a
little playbook to understand kind of
what you actually need to set things up
we're going to talk about read from star
and read from where last left off right
so when you're reading the stream
you tell the broker we're in the stream
you want to read to read from so that
could be the last place that was left
off or at the beginning and there's been
a lot of talk in the mailing list as
well between well you know I want a
durable system and after I read
something for the stream I've got to
make sure that it's been committed and I
can't do that with a high level consumer
and like oh my god how do I do that
right so I'm gonna talk to you about how
you can do that with high level consumer
and not use the low level consumer API
so if you're looking for that kind of
stuff definitely stay tuned we'll get to
that but I'll also kind of point you to
the low level API it's there you know go
for it I personally like the high level
consumer there's a lot of good stuff
that you can do with it and workaround
for all the benefits that it has the
trade offs and using the low level API
is really got to be you know powerful
and then we're gonna talk about brokers
we'll talk a little bit more about
partitions and kind of round out the
whole what is a partition will talk
about load balancing producers load
balance and consumers will talk about in
fact in sync replicas sets and what all
that means and then kind of end the talk
with client api's and how else you can
access Kafka without just using Scala
because all my examples are in Scala
okay so let's start with producers right
so again topics producer sends data to
topics right producers also have to know
about brokers right a broker is
essentially your central point of your
commit log sync producers a sync
producers and that a sync sync aqua
producer all right so setting up
producers to lines of code
pretty simple all right you basically
say which topic you want this to produce
to and which brokers you're trying to
send the data to right if you have a
cluster of three brokers then you're
gonna have three brokers in the list
here and then you go ahead and send the
message and that's it right
cough good supports bites really wants
bites you've got to give it bites if you
want to send something that's not bites
that's okay just turn it into bites
right and some people use topics to
actually figure out you know different C
realizations right so which which topic
has what cereals
in format or even dynamic see
realizations I'll talk a little bit of
that more when we get to consumers under
the hood the Kafka producer Klaus that I
created this is doing a lot of the kind
of configuration heavy lifting for you
Kafka is a lot about configuration right
so if you kind of want to pull all the
levers and everything else you've got a
kind of set the configurations right so
in my constructor
you know before by one line of code
topic and broker was dynamic I'm here
I'm saying let's make it a synchronous
producer so let's talk about synchronous
producer since I've decided to default
it to that so a synchronous producer is
basically when you as the producer
you're going to wait for the broker to
tell you whether or not the data has
been saved and you have a lot of
flexibility around that you can say to
the broker okay for this topic the
replication factor is 3 you have 3
brokers but I don't want to have a
success unless two of the replicas
already wrote the data okay and if two
of the brokers are down and you can't
write the data to two brokers you're
gonna get an error you're gonna get an
exception right that's choosing
consistency you wanna now you have to
deal with that exception right but
that's the trade-off that you're making
to have durability is that right you now
have to deal with not being able to
write to the commit log or you accept
that I want to write to the commit log
there are three brokers one of them is
down okay I've written to two of them
yay my date is in two places fantastic
even better if it's on two separate
racks right so the synchronous producer
really allows you to have a very tight
relationship with the broker now it also
is synchronous okay if you're gonna do
10,000 connections into the broker your
synchronously going to do 10,000
connections to the broker so you're now
starting to trade off your internal
infrastructure and communication the
infrastructure for you know this
synchronicity well that's where the
async producer comes in and these next
few parameters so compression is pretty
obviously fresas the data right
but batch size okay batch size is a
really important parameter when you're
sending something asynchronous okay
that's you just set synchronously to
false
but this producer will do is take all of
your messages okay it'll respond to the
producer right away that one line of
code that's saying send message just
respond right away so within 200
microseconds you know you've already
produced something to the queue and
it'll put it on its own queue and it'll
start filling up the queue until it hits
the batch size here 200 right and then
once it hits 200 or it's been 5 seconds
it will then take all of that and in one
connection and one transmission send
that over to the program so you can see
if you're in a you know an environment
where you've got more than one message
per second maybe two or three per second
maybe a thousand per second right this
becomes very very exciting because not
only can you batch messages right but
you can have you can reduce the herd
effect that's going to come with
everyone trying to talk with everyone
else inside of your network right
asynchronous is obviously going to be
faster than synchronous and you may want
to decide that you know for certain type
of messages that you're producing
asynchronous is you know more than good
enough one good example so Kafka comes
with a log4j offender so who's ever used
log4j before so Kafka has a producer
that's a log4j offender producer so if
you're already doing log4j then tomorrow
you can start producing all of that data
to Kafka now great perfect use case for
putting that asynchronous right if you
lose 10 milliseconds worth of data not a
big deal you learn 10 seconds worth of
data
yep probably not a big deal either right
if you're all of a sudden putting in you
know bookings for a hotel room let's say
right you know what you can't lose data
right so one book to hotel room you
don't want to be the guy or the girl
that is responsible when someone went to
the hotel and said oh I had a
reservation I'm sorry mr. Stein but
you're you know the hotels all booked up
you got to go someone you don't want you
don't want to do that right so it's
different information and different
messages needs to have different levels
of consistency and availability
depending on whatever domain you're
working in and even in different parts
of components within the domain the
Kafka allows for all of that a couple
more my fictitious laser pointer a
couple more
configuration items here yeah I guess
not really compressions compression you
have to compress the data or you don't
sending the message this is pretty
straightforward in my simple Kafka
producer I am making the decision that
if there's ever an error sending that
I'm just you know killing the entire
producer that's my level of like if
there's a problem then shut down right
go into bunker mode there are some
control you have here with like message
send max retries right so the producer
will try three times before it actually
fails you know you may want to make that
10 you may want to make you know the
time it takes a little bit longer you
may want to implement this to not exit
or do something differently it's all
open source is part of the sample
project that I created so you know
please feel free to you know use this
Kafka producer as your own template for
your own producers okay so lots more
configurations so many that it was like
three slides and I deleted them all
because we'd just be sitting here
talking about configurations go check
out the docs the docs are really awesome
again all the configurations are
actually in the producer config dot
Scala file so it's very well commented
it explains exactly what every
configuration is doing I'd say go check
that out and you can see you know
exactly what the configuration is to set
you know how many replicas you want to
write to I think it's like request
replica AK or something like that it
doesn't matter go look at the
configurations and you can see exactly
what they're doing for what you need to
okay so here's the akka producer right
why would you want to have an aqua
producer okay so synchronously you know
synchronicity is good and important for
durability of your data when you need to
have very strong consistent writes but
ultimately you want to make some
decision in your application about how
is that actually working and that
actually is a really good use case for
akka if folks are not familiar with akka
it's an asynchronous reactive framework
that allows you to build pools of
actors that are pinned to a core alright
very very cool good stuff on building
systems and in this in this actor it's
really basically just taking a message
and producing it on the producer right
it's actually just sending a message on
the producer and it's going to sing send
that synchronously now why is that cool
it's cool because the acha system if you
set up let's say 20 actors right it
still has a mailbox straight you don't
actually have to say that this message
has been sent on the queue inside of
your application so if you're doing any
type of audit or reconciliation you can
move that audit and reconciliation logic
into the actor system so after the actor
system is going to actually just have
every many actors they're all let's say
there's 20 right and you're throwing it
a thousand messages per second if all of
a sudden all 20 actors you know lose
connection to the broker right they're
all gonna sit there not process any
other messages because it's in order and
all 20 are just gonna sit and block and
wait if they're successful at that point
synchronously you can write back there
the auditing aspect of what you've just
done while the rest of your application
doesn't have to get bogged down by it
right so the rest of your application is
still running and still processing and
doing what it needs to do because it's
working
a synchronously with the Kafka producer
actor but then still internally within
your application if something goes wrong
you can deal with it right you can now
make different decisions within your
code about how you want to do things and
if something goes right as it should and
continuously does at that point you can
write your auditing and reconciliation
within the actor so this is a good way
to extract the needs of doing something
consistently with trying to be more
reactive in your application it's just
another layer of where you can put
things we could also jump into the
producer dot Scala code and you know
update it there a lot of different ways
to solve the same problem but this is
one that I've been working on for a
while and I see it having some good
benefits in the community so I hope
folks check it out
all right any questions I usually like
to ask questions for the end so but if
there's anything that's like just so
gripping that you just can't wait to the
end to ask you got like three seconds
okay cool
so consumers all right so let's talk a
little bit more about topics but let's
do it on the partition level
okay so topics are really a way of
organizing partitions okay your broker
must hold all of the data for any one
topic on the entire broker so if you
only have two terabytes of space per
broker then you can't make your topic
larger than what would be a two terabyte
window right that's just how it works on
the partition side you want to break up
your partitions in such a way that you
can parallel lies your consumers right
partitions are a way to parallel lies
and concurrently run your consumers
we'll talk about that a little bit read
from start right so I had mentioned
before do you want to start the
beginning of the stream or do you want
to just pick up at the end of the stream
you have both of those traces so here's
the coffee consumer as it stands now
this coffee consumer is assumed to be a
single thread right if you need to have
ten coffee consumers to actually achieve
the concurrency that you need to process
a stream and maybe another ten to have
high availability around that then now
you're looking at ten partitions right
you want to have one partition for every
one thread of consumed work that you do
right now I said ten for redundancy well
that's where the group ID comes in so
your group ID is basically how you tell
your consumers how to work together
right so you might have one group ID
that is the okay we're all gonna get
together and there's 20 of us right
there's ten partitions but there's 20 of
us and we're all gonna work together and
we're gonna be a you know maybe a coffee
cup out for sorum we're all gonna take
the data and write it to Cassandra or
we're gonna move the data into Hadoop or
push it to s3 or you know send it off to
reman or whatever right consumers are
just working together when you start up
all twenty consumers let's say you start
them up on two machines right sorry ten
on one machine ten on the other only ten
of those active threads are gonna pin to
a partition the other ten are really
there for fault tolerance so if a
machine dies all right that consumer
group of Group A all of the consumers
will rebalance to make sure that every
single partition is still being streamed
from this is a really important concept
when it comes to what you need to do
with consumers and how you need to write
them right you write consumers in a
single-threaded way right the the
ordering of data that comes into Kafka
is done on a partition level right at
the partition so you've got to think
single-threaded how do I just have this
one partition in this one piece of data
and how do i process it when you want to
make that system multi-threaded you add
partitions and those partitions then
allow you to start multiple threads that
read off those partitions and do things
concurrently or end or in parallel
across different machines I've got it
passing the zookeeper connection so the
kauffman consumers much like the brokers
which we'll get to in a sec coffee
consumers heavily yuzu keeper to keep
track of where they are on the stream
right so the scalability that we talked
about before and the speed of Kafka so
much of it comes from the broker not
having to know where people are reading
from it in the stream right that is
moved to the consumer right a lot of
scalability comes from that but in order
for it to work the consumer has to know
where did I last read in stream and then
tell the broker
hey I last read it you know offset three
six to seven five and then the next time
it says it has to come and say now I
want to read three six to seven six and
seven and eight and nine and and the
rest so a zookeeper attracts that now
the way that zookeeper tracks that and
let's talk about reach from startup
stream or not the way that zookeeper
tracks that is asynchronous right as
you're reading off of the consumer right
the high level consumer a back a
background thread every 10 milliseconds
is writing as a zookeeper saying oh this
is where I read from this is where I
read from this is where I've read from
every time the
seconds so if the consumer dies you're
gonna lose ten seconds of offsets right
that's just how it is you're gonna lose
ten seconds of offsets and for folks
some folks money folks for some datasets
like that doesn't work well I'm gonna
propose another way that you can use the
high-level consumer and still have what
you need from a offset committed
perspective you could you can keep track
of the offsets as the zookeeper
connection is running right you could
just keep track of it and if you start
from the beginning of the stream every
single time you start then you could
just ignore up until where you last
stored the upset
now since Kafka ultimately is streaming
data with very little latency across
your network and if you have 100
megabytes well you know what's gonna
it's gonna take you a second to catch up
on everything that was read from the
beginning in the stream right so you've
got a balance like how many how much
data is actually in there right do you
have like six terabytes of data at the
beginning of the stream and it's gonna
take you hours to read from the
beginning okay maybe you should take a
look at the low-level API that's the
link you can go look at the low-level
API right but if you can if you can
sacrifice some time when a consumer
comes back online to go through all the
offsets and said did it did it did it
there I am I haven't done this one yet
then who cares what's stored in
zookeeper right you can then start
paying attention to the data that's
coming off the stream knowing where it's
been written right from your own system
and then you know do whatever business
logic you wanted you want it eventually
the zookeeper consumer will catch up and
you know that's fine so that's oh that's
an option
it's one that I hope you know folks
start to look at as an option instead of
lots of people trying to rewrite the low
love of consumer to do all these
different things we'll see how that goes
all right so whitelists and blacklists a
little talk about whitelists and
blacklists and what's going on there so
you can say since topics are really
dynamic a lot of companies actually just
generate like topics dynamically
completely you may have events - and
then some UUID ok and you may have
another topic that's um you know
purchases - in the UUID or some our time
stamp or whatever it is
so whitelists and blacklists are
basically a way to regex and filter
saying okay I want everything that is of
type topic tests right and really you
know getting away from having to have oh
these are the 6,000 topics that I need
to look at I mean that's a little crazy
right if you have thousands of topics
you don't want to have to like literally
put all those in so whitelists and
blacklists are kind of a way to you know
get it all the topics that you want in a
single line of code and what I've done
here in the cockpit consumer hopefully
this will let people want to write
function programming a little bit more
this cough scan consumer except for the
configurations really never has to be
touched again what I'm doing here and
the read is I'm actually taking the
function in okay so the function write
is getting passed into the function beat
okay and with that function write is
doing is whatever the person wants to
implement when they call it the function
okay what's happening here is when it
comes off of the message stream right
and for message and topic from stream
when it's coming off with the message
stream it calls the function that was
passed into it so if you're using this
kafka consumer you can implement that
function to output to you know system
that out you could use this function to
write to s3 you could write this
function to email your mom I mean
whatever you want to do you write the
function to do that and you just pass
that function into read and read will go
ahead and you know run that operation so
fundamentally you never have to write a
consumer ever again with this code all
you have to do is just implement the
function of how you want to process the
message and figure out how you want to
paralyze all your consumers and you
never read a consumer again
a lot of this was actually the
inspiration for doing these examples
because I don't write consumers anymore
I've been writing consumer in like two
years like I just keep hearing people
writing this new consumer might be okay
so this is a way not to have to write
consumers again you know configurations
aside all right so that low-level
consumer all right you just have to deal
and work with the stream yourself you
want to talk to the brokers go for it
it's really simple to do there's a
application the simple consumer shell is
actually a full-fledged you know command
line consumer that will do everything
you want with a low level API so go
check it out I've used it a couple times
it works great I know there was some
talk and I don't know if it's here we
were talking about how to reverse the
stream and read backwards on the stream
right low level API perfect for that
kind of stuff all right so this is my
kind of wackadoodle example basically
what I said to myself was like alright
how would I create like Kafka Perpetual
old machine so what I did was create a
topic and called the topic pump you know
publisher right it's all the publisher
data that's going into the Kafka is
gonna be publisher I have a consumer the
consumer is gonna read off of the topic
and I'm gonna create a consumer group
called loop and I'm gonna throw my
broker in here all of this will work
completely out of the box from that
example project once you spin up the VMS
right because it's just gonna go to
those IP addresses that's running we're
gonna start two actors right so akka has
the ability to route to your actors in
different ways you can route by who has
the smallest mailbox you can do custom
routing you know I'm just doing ground
robin here so if it's - it'll route to a
then to B then to a them to B then to a
them and loop through this really quick
and just throw in the unit parameter is
just this quick simple way to throw in
the unit parameters back to the consumer
side
alright too many slides back that's
right
and then I'm gonna go ahead and I'm
gonna implement what I was talking about
this define exact where it's taking in
binary objects right that binary object
that's taking in this is going to be
what's taken from the kafka stream and
given to you in this code right and in
this code what I want to do is I want to
take this binary object I'm gonna turn
into a string and I'm gonna send it back
into a coffee producer ok just boom PDC
Bank message goes right back in now what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go and send in
two messages into the coffee cup
producer alright so this will go to
alright so just in case I don't know
this this function hasn't been called
yet right it hasn't been used this is
just a function that I'm just setting up
and just waiting on the side I'm now
gonna throw in two more messages to my
aqua coffe co-producer bang bang two
messages go in message goes to a message
goes to B they both write synchronously
to the broker okay and then I'm gonna
sit and I'm gonna block consumer dot
read blocks okay cuz it's gonna sit
there and just be down the stream it's
gonna go when it's gonna read on the
stream but what happens is that I'm
passing in this exact function this
exact function is what is happening
inside of that read so every single time
something comes back off of the stream
from Kafka this function gets called and
what does this function do it puts it
right back on the producer right so here
what's gonna happen is just a loop right
you're gonna take stuff off the stream
and you can put it back on the stream
and this is actually kind of useful I
know it sounds a little weird but this
is pretty useful
why because you change that number from
two to a thousand and now all of a
sudden setting your messages you want to
make them a megabyte right you could
really start to get a good sense about
the way the system is working and how
its operating and what happens like when
you kill a node and what's gonna
experience at it and you know who's
gonna get the Nagios alerts and
everything else that you could think
about with you know six lines of code or
I'm not good at simple math a few lines
of code that fit on a power play
all right so let's talk about brokers so
brokers let's kind of finish up the
discussion with partitions partitions
have some good meeting when it comes to
brokers a lot of it is in the load
balancing side which we'll talk about
talk about load balancing and producers
load balancing and consumers we'll talk
a little bit about replication I've been
using zero point eight for like two
years now I think at this point almost
like a year and a half I guess I take it
for granted that everyone's like who
replication just came out and like whoo
okay like I you know kind of get lost in
where we are and the release cycles but
yeah replications been out for a while
you know beta one came out lots of folks
ran in production a lot of good feedback
all that feedback went into 0.8 so
please you know try it out it's it's
good stuff we'll talk a little bit about
the way the in replica sets work and
then we'll also talk a little about the
client API and the wire protocol just
about enough information that'll make
your eyes want to bleed the wire
protocol is really awesome I love it
it's a completely custom based tcp/ip
exchange of byte buffers if you like
that kind of stuff let's talk afterwards
it's fun if you are trying to write your
own library you're gonna have to like
the stuff or I'll point you to all the
different client libraries and all
different languages that exist today
okay so partitions make up a topic this
is a pretty standard Kafka diagram that
is like been around for a while but I
figured I have to have one in there so
this is the anatomy of a topic as rights
are coming in to a topic it is going to
send them to a partition based on how
you've decided okay to partition that
data across the different partitions so
you could have the partitions just you
know hash and modulus you may want to
have it so that all of a specific user
right is going to go to different
partitions so all of your user data for
a specific users always in the same
partitions you know maybe you want to
partition things by IP address right if
you're
security system and your consumers
looking at all of the data and one
consumer is specifically trying to
figure out whether or not someone is
trying to you know log into the system
well you know what IP address may not be
good maybe you want to do it on username
because if someone tries to log in with
you know one username at one IP address
and another username in another IP
address well that's not valid how can
the same user be at two different IP
addresses at once that would be an alert
but maybe you also want to look at the
data by IP address maybe you want to see
that from the same ip address you know
six different people are trying to log
in within the same second that's
probably fraudulent right so depending
on you know what topic of data you're
sending in it's it's very much like you
knows like everyone says like you're
using Cassandra or HBase or something
you got to think about the query first
now right well this is still this is the
same kind of thing you've got to think
about a little bit more what are you
going to do to consume that data or just
be accepted that when you consume it
you're going to be doing transformations
at that time it's very fast because when
rites happen the cylinder doesn't really
have to do anything more than just move
up one then it just had before and since
Jah since Kafka uses Java and IO there's
no user copy it's all in kernel space
did it come straight from the socket and
goes right to disk and when it goes into
disk it's going to go into these
different partitions and again the data
in the partition is ordered but not
across partition
all right so topics will not guarantee
ordering you're only guaranteed ordering
in a partition okay so partitions do
have some more uses that are important
and depending on your scale you need to
think about if you have three brokers
and you have one topic and you have one
partition that's probably not a good
idea because you're not going to be able
to load balanced across your booker's
what Kafka does is it figures out how
many partitions there are and then make
sure that different brokers are the
leader for those partitions so if we
have one topic and we have three
partitions and we have three brokers
then what Kafka will do is it will
designate broker 1 to be the leader for
partition 1 it will designate broker 2
to be the leader for partition 2 and
broker 3 will be the leader for purchase
so when the producers are sending data
and it knows it now it needs to send
data to three it's gonna send it to
broker three right so natural effective
load balancing the data that you're
producing across all the different
brokers so a lot of scalability comes
from that as well by being able to
distribute the load to the different
brokers and not just have one broker
that everything is you know being
written to and the others are slaves so
you can look at this as a active active
system by using partitions to make them
active active where each partition and
of itself right is active slave slave or
whatever other was there similarly on
the consumer side you also get some load
balancing right here in this is example
consumer group a you can see that we
have two servers and four partitions
consumer group a and consumer group a
can run be running on you got two
different servers so we could have
server run running c1 which is a
consumer and consumer group a and server
2 which is running you know c thun
server group a and each of those are
going to you know pull off of to the
different partitions if one of those
fails then Kafka is going to assign all
four partitions to that other consumer
right so here is another way to
accomplish load balancing and
scalability and really where partitions
come in because here if you want to have
one partition in one consumer right good
supergroup B you need to set this up
accordingly if you set up five six seven
eight
none of those are going to get any data
unless the first four fail and if the
first four fail then Kafka will
rebalance and start giving partition
data to those other consumers okay so
how does the replication work so
replication is twofold
okay replication is how Kafka moves the
data to other replicas and then on the
producer side what are your decisions
about what are your guarantees when
you're actually producing the data which
we had talked about right sending the
data synchronously having a number of
replicas that are acting
what happens in the background on the
broker as if let's say server one here
is the leader for a partition and it
gets some data and your replication
factor is three right it's going to send
a right request to server to send the
right request to server three and then
wait for responses for an act from
server 2 and an act from server 3 if you
set your producer as a synchronous
producer and you say wait for two
acknowledgments then you're going to be
sitting and waiting for these round
trips to happen and that might be
important and useful in what you want to
do but maybe not this is gonna happen no
matter what right whether you produce
something and you don't care to get a
response back or not this is the same
replication that's going to happen right
server one get some information right
sit to 2 2 will act or not it'll right 2
3 3 will act or not if you want some
more information on replication
Shriram was one of the committers he did
a great job at the second user group
Kafka meeting which is streamed there
really great job talking about it
June rouse slides also talk about it
we've talked about it afterwards
afterwards as well you really want to
get too much into how does coffee
replication works it's just so much
content out on Google the internet that
you can get trying to give some more
information in detail and try to get a
little closer to community about you
know what what's going on ok so the
client API so there's a guide to
developing with the Kafka protocol again
the Kafka protocol is a custom tcp/ip
wire protocol for non JVM clients other
people of you know take it upon
themselves to actually go and build
libraries that use this protocol so
David Arthur is one of the committers he
maintains the Python library there's a
high performance e library as well it
has full protocol support Adobe labs
maintains the C++ library there's a go
or go Lang however you want to call it
pure go implementation that now supports
Kafka is all zero this is all zero it's
tough there's some other things 4:07
night he's a PHP one and anode and
Erlang and what-have-you
it's also a ruby library and a closure
library as well so even if you don't use
Java or Scala Kafka is very happy to not
really care about that and that's why
there's this custom wire protocol it'll
speak to any language that can properly
you know support the protocol and send
data back and forth on it and you know
these are all libraries that have you
know been open source and are used by
folks so yeah so it's not so much non
JVM as it is it's not supported by the
Apache project okay that's fair yeah so
the Apache project only supports the
Scala and then we have some Java
wrappers around the Scala api's just so
that you don't have to deal with dollar
signs and stuff like that it's kind of
kind of weird going from Scala into Java
so there's some Java API is that rap
that you just call the Java API so it
feels more Java like I guess I don't
know if I should apologize for that or
not but that's what it is I mean I'm
glad they're there I just haven't
apologized that people are still using
Java realize that not everyone
understood what I was saying all right
so yeah my name is Joe Stein I started
this company Big Data open source
security guess what we do it's not just
security we do open source projects and
client implementations and trying to
figure out and build all the blue code
for hooking together systems like Kafka
and Cassandra and Hadoop and really
focus on business domain implementations
for companies I'm on Twitter or email
you guys want to you know check me out
or go talk or if anyone has questions
now shoot
sure okay so when you're when you're
consuming data okay you're consuming
data from a topic but you're doing more
than just consuming data from a topic
because what you're really doing is you
need to figure out how that data is
going to get processed okay if you can
have a single message coming off the
Kafka queue and let's say that takes a
second to process just takes a second
right well it's gonna do that in a
single threat right so every second is
going to process a piece of data right
if you have a thousand of those right so
okay I want to I'm gonna put that in a
thread pool right I want to make that
concurrent and I want to paralyze it
right that's the natural effective what
you would do so the way that you do that
in Kafka is you write those two
different partitions right if you want
to have a thread pool let's say of you
know size 10 so you can do 10 messages
at a time then you would create 10
partitions here you set up the consumer
groups in such a way so that you can
either read off of the same stream at
the same time or you can read off of the
same stream but with other people
participating as well okay so in
consumer group a you have two
participants you have two consumers but
you have four partitions so Kafka is
gonna say all right I'm gonna give you
two partitions to read out them and give
you two partitions in this scenario
where you have one consumer for every
partition it's basically like one
consumer for every partition and if you
had four or five or six or let's say you
add consumer group C right you need to
start to think about the data pipeline
as how you're consuming data and what
you're doing with it and that then is a
direct result of how you want to set up
your partitions because you need to know
how you're gonna parallel is that are
you gonna make a concurrent right if you
have more partitions and more consumers
than the other partitions when some died
it can be balanced and then be able to
you know how they keep going
something could be wrong in your design
depending on and this is something that
is different between 0 7 & 0 8 is that
in zero 7 the if you didn't put in a
partition key in 0 7 a no partition key
would actually round-robin all of your
data to multiple partitions in 0.8
doesn't do that anymore right the
assumption is that you have enough
producer sending enough data into the
system and the partition the producers
will grab onto different leaders and as
a natural effective data come in you'll
get randomness as far as that goes if
you don't then what you need to do is
start using a partition key okay the
partition key could be anything
you know UUID dot random UUID to string
but some partition key you've got to
give it some partition key if you still
find hot spots in your partitions well
you've got to start to rethink you know
what are you petitioning on all right
let's say you partition on an account ID
or a publisher ID and all of a sudden
that one publisher just through thousand
times X more data right and now that
partition is getting nailed with a
thousand times more data well maybe your
partition key needs to be a little bit
more granular right if you can't and you
can't write you've got a you know figure
out how to deal with that like so
definitely vary the answer really comes
down to what's the data look like you
know did main specific use case scenario
talk about
yep
okay
yeah so there's been some talk about
that and some write-ups whether to use
ext4 ext3 and how you do that I'm a I'll
admit like I've always had good
experiences ext3 I think that if you
want to use ext4 or XFS or some other
file system that would be okay there are
some controls in Kafka that from a
configuration perspective can help you
reduce that file system caching so that
might be a good place to look as well I
would say you know check out the
operations Docs you know shooting email
if need be otherwise you know go with
what you're comfortable with there's not
there there hasn't been shown to be a
lot of different benefit to using
different file systems at least not yet
yeah so that that's in there and 0.8
yeah so let's go back I should have
actually ended on this slide as well
okay so here the tool so there the
replication tools there are eight of
them I guess so you can create new
partitions reassigned petitions and
replicas and you could do a lot of
functionality when it comes to tooling
the brokers and and making a lot of
changes I think really the only thing
that you can't do or yet in zero eight
versus zero one is delete partitions
otherwise most anything else that you
would expect to want to do you can do in
zero eight 1 sorry 0 8 0 if you want to
delete partitions then you've got to use
0 8 1 ok so there's a lot of you know
besides replication a lot of bug fixes
came out in zero 8 as well so if you're
using 0 7 and it's stable of course keep
using it right like why change something
in production that's you know not broken
but if you're going to get into it to
begin with are you looking to upgrade
there's a migration tool that you can
see in the Kafka tools directory that'll
help you migrate 0 7 data to 0 8 right
the wire protocol is completely
different and changed you cannot connect
to 0 8 brokers with 0 7 producers and
vice versa the wire protocol was thought
thoughtfully put together so that that
won't happen anymore but it happened now
so my recommendation would be you know
get up on 0 8 0
besides replication a lot of other fixes
and features inside of there things like
Bob compaction and there's so many
features that have not even been talked
about or discussed that are in Kafka
that are really beneficial as you're
trying to operate on a day to day basis
that are in zero eight zero that you
just kind of always wanted zero 7 right
there they're now in zero eight
yeah so it doesn't so there is but so
there is another project and I want to
say it starts with the W I can't
remember the actual github URL every
time I see it coming to Kafka sorry the
storm user group I always like respond
hey this one guy got a zero eight spouts
working or what have you so he has a
zero eight spouts working that a bunch
of folks I know have used very
successfully as far as the Apache Kafka
Scout spout goes when the proposal for
the storm incubator came about I totally
threw my hand up there and was like hey
what about the Kafka spout right so the
Kafka spout is part of the Apache
project for storm so I would say now
that it's zero eight zero it's just
waiting for one of you to go in and do
the upgrade I could help if you want no
problem but it's you know it's it's just
a matter of someone going and
contributing it in or using the one I
can't remember
catch me afterwards I've tried to send
it to the storm list again or tweeted it
I up top my head I forget which one it
is but there is one that sports it
something to fix you know if we can get
people off of zero seven then they have
to have all the different you know
downside streams that they expect right
totally another awesome exciting thing
about storm is now it's part of the
Apache project which is great
they're already online yeah so I you
could either go to my Twitter which is
all things to do by tweeted out the link
or I'm charm Alec on SlideShare if you
just google slide share charm Alec or
SlideShare Joe Stein or something it'll
come up it's on my SlideShare yep so
charmella cousin like char
maybe
yeah so yeah so I'll speak to the second
part of that and the first part the
Netflix to the Netflix developers
actually spoke at the second user group
online so if you want to see what
Netflix was doing six months ago with
Kafka just get it from their mouth but
as far as the queuing system goes really
think of Kafka not as a queuing system
or not as a message brokering system but
truly as a commit lock okay it is the
journal for all of the events that
happen within your infrastructure okay
LinkedIn sends sixty billion events
every day into Kafka clusters okay
that's pretty good and what they get out
of it is a journal commit log of
everything that happened ordered in time
and ordered in a way that they can then
consume it and then they could scale the
consumers to consume things continuously
right they could have batch jobs that go
in and replay the entire day they could
have six different streams that sit
there and watch the data and transform
it into any type of OLAP cube that all
their customers want right that's really
the benefits that Kafka brings and it's
important to think of it as a
centralized commit lock with messaging
features
I have not when it was first announced I
went to go look for it and it did that
uh like it wasn't actually there and
they had some other dataflow pipeline
product and I got really upset about it
but I've heard good things about it you
know I've heard that it actually uses
some of the same patterns that Kafka
uses which is great you know I think
that you know the more systems that are
out there that do similar things we get
to understand you know what are the
trade-offs that we're making like for me
solutions are about not just solving
problems but deciding all the trade-offs
we want to like deal with either as
individuals or as organizations so
having a service based system that does
similar things I think is awesome have
not played fit for me I'd rather just
take some graphical brokers and throw
him in ec2 if I was gonna do that but
anybody else yeah
every single message has to come through
so on the brokers to us are on the
producer side you want to do a
synchronous producer right obviously and
you want to have your replica sets be
whatever your tolerance is for data loss
to a specific broker so let's say your
requirement is okay as long as two racks
have the data I'm good okay so maybe
setting up three brokers one in each
rack with replication of three and
having the sync be you know a replica of
two you can lose one note all right that
may be a good way to go about it could
be on the consumer side really you're
just spinning up consumers and letting
the rebalance or take control right it
doesn't matter if you have one topic in
one partition or 60 topics and 60,000
partitions that's a development decision
that you have to make when figuring out
how to consume the data and process it
mount one from availability that makes
sense and you can do everything with one
topic in one partition right like I've
actually done that
I pushed hundreds and millions and you
know pieces of data through a topic and
partition on zero seven and it works
great or it's great on zero eight right
but it comes down to like what are you
doing with that data right if you're
just writing it to Cassandra that's
gonna go really fast okay you're writing
it to Oracle you might have to have
sixty thousand partitions to you know
parallel what I don't know but I
promised not to Oracle bash I'm sorry I
guess I'll have to wait to Larry Ellison
to come up and catch me somewhere and
say something all right any other
questions I'll be here all evening
all right well thank you everybody